assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters dear
friends welcome to my channel hope you
guys are doing well obviously you guys
might be a well if the last week the
shooting that happened about a day ago
two days ago what we did is we fought
you know what obviously is a tragic
event and this charge covers happening
all over the world this it's happening
in Burma right now it's happening it's
all over the world it's happening so
it's what madness but the thing that we
wanted to highlight as well besides the
tragic event is that how the media once
again the bias that we're using and
quadlings in division division of wolf a
lone wolf a killer a crazed man or
whatever it may be so what we for is
let's go to the streets of London and
speak to some people and get their take
on an awesome if this was a Muslim who
committed this act
how would it how would have been like
you know would have been indifferent and
why is that the case so let's go and
find out if you know what happened
yesterday in Las Vegas if the
perpetrator was a Muslim how do you
think the headlines would have been what
do you really think that would be the
case you know happy new city
in Las Vegas there's a mass shooting
yeah and this guy's a killer yeah it's a
white guy oh if this was a Muslim what
do you think the heading will be what do
you think the headlines would be if this
guy was a Muslim straight away I was
saying it's daylight even if he wasn't
black
well that's to you when I saying this
terrorist but you know it's come out
he's got mental illness at something
like I mean if he's not Muslim or maybe
if he's not black he's mentally ill so
why do you think that is why do you
think this double standard is in place
because of the racist governments that
we have my personal Trump in America
who's straightaway a fascist Xenophon
yeah like he doesn't like people for not
be an American like and then he doesn't
love you for being Muslim black Mexican
wherever because of that it's leaning
towards the white/blue any first so I
personally feel like white privilege but
I also feel guilt for being white any
situations like well even an SSI where
inherently am I even thinking about this
a white life cost more than
you know that's that's very powerful we
just set them straight you thank you
guys for taking any time out speaking
after so if that was a Muslim what do
you think they would have taken that's
Paris
that's how the media trying to portray
it you know I said the killer yeah if
this if this was a Muslim what do you
think why what was it what's the
difference between this guy and those
that back besides one of them shouts in
Arabic but what's the difference
we're just wondering if the perpetrator
was a Muslim how do you think the
headline would have been what what do
you think they use instead of killing
terrorists what because fear-mongering
again because of the Western world and
taller and like Eastern ideas like Islam
and just general misrepresentations of
what Islam is but see this headline here
in today's newspaper says killer amassed
arsenal forty two guns what do you think
the headlines would be you know what
happened yes okay if the perpetrator was
a he was a Muslim only brown people can
be terrorists
yeah what do you think the tattoo what I
mean oh it would have been well double
of me for any evidence that is a Muslim
research I know what they do like
Saracen yeah okay
it's the same this guy this guy's they
look at that they've done the killings
now if you look at this headline killer
amassed arsenal 42 guns before
unleashing deadly sweep what what do you
think the head killer
so it sort of Lee so why do you think
that the headlines are so different when
like and his racist never mentioned its
religion you know this shooting is one
of the deadliest shootings in the u.s.
in American history yeah I used to
believe in the u.s. my outside my school
there was a police car in all days just
in case someone was going to do
something because the media has
demosceners when his body fell to white
killers and white terrorists the same
day there was killings taking place in
another part of the world in Burma I'm
happening generally every day so I mean
in Burma India the rahega yeah exactly
so you know yeah so I'm actually
surprised that you know because a lot of
people to actually don't know about this
it might have away international
relations students you've seen for
yourself now what I want to do is I
didn't get much of a conversation but
I'm also going to a bit of a good
conversation
yeah we've you know I mean I'm sure you
guys saw the conversations face off so
I'm not going to talk too much about
what we discuss here because you know
Cory but one thing that made me feel
happy
yeah and a little bit better about
what's going on in the world is that
there are certain people that aren't
necessarily Muslims that do notice these
things sometimes you know on our social
media as Muslim public figures and other
Muslim you know popular pages on
Instagram and whatnot we're always
talking about this the double standards
of the media look at this look at the
hypocrisy what not it's always Muslims
talking about it but it was nice bro to
see you know some people that look like
normal people that aren't necessarily
Muslim talking about they're saying yes
I've seen the double standards there was
one guy I mean I'm sure you guys saw it
who actually said to me he was an you
seem like an English guy but he was he
was white he was a white guy and he goes
I feel I feel so much white privilege in
this day and age I feel it so much that
I actually feel ashamed to be white so
like it's like there are people out
there guys that do understand what we go
through and there are people out there
that do understand the double standards
so on our part one thing that I do want
to say is that when you go out there and
you see English people people that
aren't wearing a hijab or whatnot
don't just generalize them the way they
just don't way the way the media
generalized us you know we need to think
that you know what there are people to
understand us somewhat not and we need
to approach it like that so when we talk
to someone you don't need to necessarily
approach everyone like everyone up there
is your enemy no I think in fact the
majority of the public out there
understanding people not very aware
people I mean that's that's what I would
have to say now one more thing I'm just
just to mention this I think we should
buy this video we're not trying to be
insensitive towards the lives lost in
Las Vegas what we were trying to
actually do through this video is show
how every latmos
every life matters exactly you know
there was the whole black lives matter
movement we're trying to show that every
single life matters if blood if black
people in Ghana are dying African people
are dying
that's African people dying that's lives
being lost if people are dying in Las
Vegas that is Laos being lost but why is
it that the media the celebrities are
always talking about Las Vegas now just
because that happened but when people
are dying in Africa no one's talking
about it yeah when people are dying in
Burma no one's talking about it you know
yeah and the reason like some people
when they come and say black lives
matter they're not saying they're not
going out there to make it seem like
they're only like no because there's a
lack of sympathy for their life that's
why they same look our lives matter too
yeah that's what we want to do today but
when we went out it's because we didn't
want to the fact that all lives don't
matter is the reason why we're going out
there to show that all life do matter
that's the reason we're going there to
do that you know it's not because we're
seeing Muslim vibes are different no of
course not so that's why what would see
is I'm just gonna wrap it up inshallah
at the end of the day this just proves
that and even there's a lot of far-right
groups and billiards races individuals
who are upset and they really wanted
this to be a Muslim
and it was it was people like you know I
you know Tommy Robinson was like I
actually saw it's been who's that
ah this something fishy going on you
know they're in denial the guy literally
did not spoke to one guy you guys would
have fully seen here but he said you
know Isis are claiming this he said to
me you know there's no maybe that's
absolutely BS they claim everything they
claim everything they claimed hurricane
movie use a Muslim yeah exactly
so that's why anyway watch the video
where we'll see Miz in Burma and
inshallah do support the people there as
well as well as I think there's a
campaign going on for the people the
victims in America so do we'll put the
links at the end do support both of them
inshallah
and watch this heart-touching video at
the end of it and share this with your
friends and family
assalamu Reformatory better care to the
next time share it with your friends and
family goodbye day that you need not
knowing whether you're gonna get where
your next meal is coming from
only thing that's on these lips suppose
that's the only thing that he's not left
to say I don't need to say anything do
whatever you can to support them and to
help them
[Music]
[Music]
yeah